字幕: Mari Arimitsu
校正: Takahiro Shimpo
私は今から35年前
ここ京都のお寺で生まれました
お寺の子供として育ちましたけれども
中学校・高校は
カトリックの学校に行っておりました
（笑）
お寺に生まれながらにして
キリスト教の教育を受ける
これは非常に
珍しいことではありますけれども
家族 それから親族
友達を含め
皆 暖かく見守ってくれました
大学時代に私
アイルランドに行ったことがありました
アイルランドはご存知の通り
敬虔なカトリックの国ですけれども
そこの ある田舎のB&Bに行った時に
女将さんに私の生い立ちを説明しました
すると 女将さんは急に顔色を変えて
次のように言いました
「あなたの国では何でそんなことができるの？
アイルランドでそんなことをやったら
あなた殺されても文句を言えないわよ」と
こういう風に言われてしまいました
私はすごく若かったので
残念ながら
その女将さんに
全く反論することができませんでした
日本人の宗教観は
非常に独特なものがあります
例えば 多くの日本人は
キリストの誕生日であるクリスマスをお祝いし
年末には お寺で除夜の鐘を聞いて
そして お正月には神社に初詣に行きます
日本以外の方からは
「なんて節操のない」という風に
言われることもあるんですけれども
しかし ここ日本では 非常に
こういった宗教の寛容性というのは
一般的です
私は この宗教の違いというのは
「食」の違いに似ているんじゃないかな
という風に思ってます
例えば和食と洋食の
違いを考えてみましょう
洋食のコース料理を頼みますと
メインディッシュというのが出てきます
そのコースのハイライトですけれども
和食には こう言った
メインディッシュというのはありません
例えば伝統的な
懐石料理を注文しますと
先付け 椀物から
最後のご飯にいたるまで
メインという考え方はありません
私は この食と同じように
この日本人の宗教観も
ある特定の宗教だけを
特別視するのではなく
全ての宗教に共通する
倫理観 もしくは哲学
こういったものを日本人は
大事にしていると思います
ですから 日本人の宗教観というのは
Believe in something
（何かを信じる）ではなくて
Respect for something（何かを敬う）
もしくはRespect for others（他者を敬う）
こういうスタイルが
日本人の宗教観です
ですから日本では
色んな宗教を信じている方が
いらっしゃいますが
お互いに尊重しておりますし
実は私がいる この妙心寺でも
お寺ですけれども 神社の神様に
お経をあげる機会も結構あります
そして お寺の中に神社がある所も
沢山あります
ですから 日本の仏教というのは
非常に特異な形をとっています
例外はありますけれども
日本のお坊さんは妻帯を許されていますし
修行中は お肉・お魚を慎んで
精進料理をいただきますが
修行が終わってしまえば
特別厳しい戒律はありません
しかし この日本では
物を残す もしくは無駄にする
こういったことは
非常に敬遠されます
もし この仏教発祥の地である
インドの方が
日本の仏教をご覧になったら
「これは仏教ではないんじゃないか」と
おっしゃるかもしれません
インド それから東南アジアを
中心として信仰されている
上座部仏教では 戒律の遵守
それから教程の学習
瞑想の修行
こういったことを
目的とされています
しかし ここ日本の仏教は
先祖供養 そして
普段の生活の中での礼節を敬う
こういったことを重視しています
じゃあ もし私たちが
今まで1500年以上かけて
築いてきた このスタイル
これを「仏教でない」というんだったら
どう呼んだらいいんでしょうか？
やはり これはどうしても
「日本の仏教」
と言うしかないと思います
日本の仏教は中国
それから日本の
古来の宗教である
神道の影響を受けて
日本に相応しい形で
洗練されてきました
ですから元々 ブッダが始めた
原始的な仏教とは
実践の方法は違いますけれども
インドにしろ 東南アジアにしろ
ここ日本にしろ
その根底にあるのは
ブッダが唱えられた
素晴らしい哲学と教義に
基づいています
私は 日本とインドの
この仏教の違いというのは
実はカレーに似ているんじゃないかなと
思っています
（笑）
インドでは このように
非常にスパイシーで辛いカレーを
皆さん召し上がります
カレーもインドが
発祥の地なんですけれども
このインドの方が
日本の私たちが すごく食べ慣れている
甘くてまろやかなカレー
皆 好きな方
沢山いらっしゃると思いますが
あのカレーを召し上がったら
「これカレーじゃないじゃないか」と
こうおっしゃるかもしれません
じゃあ私たちが慣れ親しんでいる
このカレー
これを何と呼んだらいいんでしょうか？
やはり私たちは これを
「日本のカレー」と
言うしかないと思います
確かに調理法・具材は
違うかもしれませんが
このルーにお肉やお魚
そして野菜を入れて煮込んで
ご飯と もしくはパンと一緒にいただく
このスタイルはインドでも日本でも
共通しています
私事ですが 私は大学時代に
農学部におりました
その農学部時代に 実はカレーに関する
ある実験を行ったことがあります
これがどういう実験かというと
まず部屋を２つ用意します
まず一つ目の部屋は
日本の夏の気候のように
すごく暑くて しかも湿度が高い
高温多湿の部屋を用意します
もう一つの部屋は
インドの夏のように
すごく暑いんだけれども
湿度があまりない
カラッとした気候の部屋を用意します
そこに世界中から集まられた
留学生も含めて
30人の学生さんに
しばらくいてもらって
その部屋の中で
インドと日本のカレー
両方 食べ比べてもらいました
そして どちらが美味しいか
判断してもらいました
すると日本の部屋で食べた
学生さんの内
30人の内 20人以上の方が
日本のカレーの方が
美味しいという回答がありました
同じこの30人が
また別の日に
このインドのお部屋で
カレーを食べた際には
インドのカレーの方が美味しいと
おっしゃった学生さんが
30人中 20人以上いらっしゃいました
つまり日本の部屋で食べた場合には
日本のカレーが
そしてインドの部屋で食べた場合には
インドのカレーの方が美味しいという
回答が得られたわけです
このように 食というのは
その土地の気候・風土
こういったものに
大きく左右されます
宗教も同じで もちろん
この気候・風土
それから歴史・文化・伝統
こういった色んな要素で
その国に相応しい形に
洗練されてまいります
私たちに馴染みのある
日本人の この寛容性のある宗教観
私は これを世界の皆様とシェアできれば
世界の皆様に
素晴らしいアイデアを提供できると
私は強く信じています
今から数年前になりますが
兵庫県に尼崎という町があります
そこで 素晴らしく画期的な
FMの番組が始まりました
この番組 タイトルは ズバリ
『8時だヨ！神さま仏さま』
といいます （笑）
元々は これは『8時だヨ！神仏集合』
だったんですけれども （笑）
それはいいとしまして
これがどういう番組かと言いますと
毎週水曜日 ８時から30分の
番組なんですけれども
ご覧のように
あるリスナーからのお悩みを
神社の神主さん 仏教のお坊さん
キリスト教の牧師さん
この３名が一緒になって解決すると
こういう番組なんです
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
これは非常に画期的で
ある宗教のお坊さんが
ある特定のものに対して回答する
これはあり得る話だと思うんですけれど
全く違う宗教のお坊さんが３人集まって
一つのお悩みを解決していく
これは前代未聞ですし
非常に画期的なプログラムです
リスナーの方にしてみれば
一つの固定化された回答だけではなくて
世の中には色んな解決方法が
あるのかということで
非常に安心感が得られます
そして もう一つ
今年の２月ですけれども
私が提案しまして
ここ京都で これまた画期的な
素晴らしいイベントを
開催いたしました
それが これ
「宗教者駅伝」です （笑）
この駅伝というのは 日本人に
非常に馴染みのある競技だと思いますが
実はこの駅伝は ここ京都で
今から百年前に生み出された競技です
この世界を代表する
宗教都市 京都
そして この駅伝の
発祥の地である ここ京都
ここに世界中から
色んな宗教の宗教家・お坊さんに
集まっていただいて
宗教家だけでつなぐ駅伝を
開催したんです
これは宗教対抗ではなくて
例えば第一走者は神社の神主さん
第二走者は仏教のお坊さん
第三走者はキリスト教の神父さん
第四走者はイスラム教の
イマームという風に
宗教をミックスして
一つの たすき をつなぐというのを
複数のチームを作って
この駅伝を開催したわけです
現代では 宗教のお互いの理解が
必要だということで
対話・対談 こういったことも
よく行われていますけれど
会議室で対談をしても
なかなか発信力がありませんし
この駅伝というのは
パッと見て分かりますから
市民の皆さんと一緒に走りますので
一体感がある そして直接的に
メッセージが伝わります
それから 走らないといけないので
必然的に若い宗教家が
活躍できるということです
そして これ実は京都だけではなくて
ヨーロッパのルクセンブルクでも
同じコンセプトの駅伝が開催されて
実はこの駅伝を介して
宗教の融和を図ろうという動きが
今 世界に広まりつつあります
ですから この混迷を極めた世の中
宗教家自らが自分の身を削って
身を挺して そして
宗教の融和を図っていく
これは私 非常に大事なことだと
思っています
さて もし私が今
大学時代にお会いした
アイルランドの
B＆Bの女将さんに
再会する機会があれば
私は今だったら 堂々と
自信を持って言えると思います
確かに全ての宗教において
その教義に忠実である・守ること
これは非常に大事なことです
しかし世の中には
もっと大切なことがあります
それは信じる宗教が違っていても
お互いを尊重し そして
仲良くするということです
日本では色んな宗教を
信じている人がいますが
宗教が違うからといって
争い・揉め事 こういったことは
ほとんど起こりません
しかしテレビでニュースを見ますと
世界を見渡しますと
一つの宗教を信じるあまり
他の宗教の方と争ったり
罵り合ったり
そういう場面が散見されます
しかし私は それは
本末転倒だと思います
宗教の本質は盲目的に
一つのものを信じることではありません
世界には沢山の人がいて
それぞれ皆さん感謝の気持ちを持って
安心感を得て そして
自分の人生を全うする
その助けを提供するのが
この宗教の役割です
ですから宗教の本質
宗教の役割というのは
安心感を与えることです
ここ日本では こうやって
様々な宗教がありますけれども
それぞれ尊重して 皆さん平和に
安心感を持って過ごされています
しかしながら この世界には
色んな地域があります
そして色んな文化・伝統があります
ですから この安心感を感じる方法は
一つじゃなくても良いと思います
色んな方法があっても良いと思います
私は この２年ほどで
前のローマ法皇にご招待いただいて
バチカンに行ったり
この４月には ここ京都で
ダライ・ラマ猊下にご招待いただいて
シンポジウムに
参加させていただきましたが
世界の宗教家が
実は日本の宗教観に
非常に期待されています
ですから私は是非 世界でも冠たる
宗教都市 ここ京都
ここ京都から
日本人の持つ素晴らしい
この寛容性のある宗教観
これを是非 世界に伝えたいと思います
そうすれば世界は
もっと素晴らしくて
素敵な場所になると
私は強く信じています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）